hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
gamespot here at the Disney infinity
booth at e3 2014 and i'm here with john
who runs Disney infinity John what do
you do so I'm actually the general
manager of all of infinity but I really
come from the game studio avalanche
software that made infinity so I've been
working there for a long time you do a
little bit of everything I imagined a
little bit of everything I do well we're
here experiencing disney infinity marvel
superheroes can you tell me a little bit
about what the buzz is here at e3 about
this game well obviously it's Marvel in
infinity so this is the first time you
can take all these fantastic characters
in Marvel and in the toy box you can
utilize them with all your favorite
Disney characters as well so we have a
bunch of different true to property
marble experiences we've got playsets
for both the Avengers as well as we're
announcing here spider-man so we're
really excited about that so you've got
all these cool figurines that you can
get to play all these favorite
characters and then we've got the toy
box mode and in the toy box mode that's
your imagination and that's where
anything goes very cool I was really
excited to see spider-man I saw the
guardians of the galaxy lots of the
Avengers we're gonna have a wide variety
of Marvel superheroes to play am i right
yeah there's going to be over 20 marvel
superheroes that you'll have by that by
the time that will kind of announced
everything so if I already have disney
infinity and i want to play marvel
superheroes walk me through how i bring
those superheroes in to play with the
disney characters i already have enough
alright so first off you've got to go
out and buy either a new starter pack
which is you know disney infinity marvel
superheroes edition so there's a starter
pack that has three different avengers
characters in it as well as an Avengers
playset now you can go in through that
door or there will also be a digital
download that if you just want to buy
the toy box you can go ahead and do that
and that will be coming out we'll be
talking about that more later but if
you've already bought Disney infinity
one you'll be able to come in through
that door as well very very cool and I
know that a lot of disney infinity is
about the story you can create and kind
of making your own disney memories as it
were we can make disney memories now
with these Marvel superhero so
personally what are you marked most
excited about in terms of those stories
being creative you
I'm actually excited by this year number
of stories that are being created out
there there we've had just a huge
response from our community with a
number of toy boxes that have been built
and submitted to Disney plus we've had
over 10 million of them downloaded by
the communities so the sharing that's
been going on in that the creativity we
get blown away all the time by stuff
that people create so what's cool about
this year is we've made it even easier
to do that so if you're somebody who
likes to build things inside of infinity
kind of have those play sessions tell
those stories to each other your
creativity is it's a lot easier to get
there you'll be able to do things much
more quickly and things are really
impressive at the same time so talk to
me about the kind of gamer that Disney
infinity really speaks to is it you know
you were talking a lot about the
creativity about the storytelling is not
really the kind of person that enjoys
this game or are there other types of
gamers to you know it actually Disney
infinity appeals to so many types of
people that's one of the things that
surprised and made us happiest is when
we started making the game we wanted to
make a game that we wanted to play with
our own kids that was the bar that we
wanted to set so it's easy enough for it
for a child to play but deep enough for
an adult to have a lot of fun at the
same time and so when we actually got
all of our data back off infinity one
that's pretty much what happened so
we've got a lot of poor gamers that play
we've got a lot of non-parent adults
that play parents play with their kids
brothers and sisters playing with each
other it's kind of all over the map well
the big news here of course is marvel
what has it been like working with
Marvel where there's there's so many
established storylines and deep floor
and things like that how will we see
that reflected and how was that
development process so a sub game geek
right so it's like I've always loved all
the Marvel superheroes so with that when
we first got the opportunity to start
working with these guys it was really
kind of a dream come true to be able to
go in talk to Joe Quesada a lot of the
guys had written all the comic books to
talk to them about how they would want
their characters brought into something
like this so one of the cool things
about working with the Marvel Universe
is there's a bunch of different versions
of all the stories have been so many
comic books TV series films that it was
cool that we got to go in and create our
own story lines working with these guys
to bring it to make sure that it really
felt true to the Marvel family great so
we're going to see new stories that also
have that depth and that familiarity
with those characters we love that's
really exciting i'm so excited to try it
out for myself thank you so much for
your time great thank you it's been
awesome let me know which character
you're most excited to play by tweeting
at Anna Prosser with the hashtag
gamespot III